[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten will heute gibt eine richtig
leckere torte und nehmen ist die torte
gebacken und außerdem ist da auch noch
richtig gesund helmrath heute gibt es
eine leckere wassermelonen torte von
außen sieht es dann nämlich aus wie eine
echte torte also wir halt so eine
gebackene torte mit viel zucker drin
aber im innern steckt hat eine echte
wassermelone also ganz viel abstand so
ein paar früchte
je nachdem was ihr da habt und ich
bestreite sie dann einfach mit bisschen
sahne noch keinen quark sahne und so
weiter nehmen
auf jeden fall ich das selbst jetzt das
rezept was ich bei meiner was es mit dem
galileo team abgedreht hatte also als
die da waren und das habt ihr schon
gesehen habt oft danach gefragt und
deswegen mache ich jetzt diese anleitung
also wichtig ich einfach gebraucht eine
wassermelone die hier ist jetzt nicht
optimal rund aber so ist halt mit
wassermelonen die wachsen ja nicht rund
oder so wie woanders im in anderen
ländern eckig ja ich kann sie ja doch
man kann die in seinem ex team wachsen
rasch den genau stimmt weggekommen auch
wachsen genau auf jeden fall müsse das
cinema und einfach mal zurechtschneiden
und ich mache das jetzt so bei mir kommt
jetzt erst mal bittet deckel weg
so kenne ich erstmal hinstelle und dann
damit ich mich jetzt hier gleich mit
schneide markiere ich mir hier war
gerecht oben nochmal rote decke menschen
zur bislang dann kann man nämlich auch
den deckel
parallel dazu am besten schneiden und
fertig aus leiterbahnen voll die
schmerzen im arm
aber das geht auch ein bisschen schwer
als die zwei kammern wegschmeißt nämlich
keiner wassermelonen dran
das stelle ich sie mir erst mal hin und
sehe es ist nicht gerade das denn
nochmal gerade schneiden bei der
wassermelone kann man ja den clubs
machen
aber eigentlich ist ein mythos
aber mein papa hat mir das so
beigebracht hat sagte wassermelone und
glaubt moment sie sich hohl anhört dann
erste reihe genau also wenn sie hole ich
machen unsere oder wenn jemand drin
sitzt genau also wenn sie hohl ist sehr
gut deswegen hast du nicht geheiratet
habe aber das sollen nun mythos sein
aber naja mein papa hat mir beigebracht
und ich mache das immer so und zwar
selber aber was stimmt umso kleiner umso
süsser und fruchtiger die zitrone
zitrone nicht als zitrone limette
jetzt müssen wir einfach außerdem auch
soziale wegschneiden vielleicht hätte
ich einfach anderes wäre hätten wir sie
ein anderes muss ich wieder voll an
zynismus
hahaha wohl habe ich mich vergriffen
jetzt einfach die seiten erst mal gerade
einschneiden
da wir müssen mal unsere messer wieder
zum schumacher ja definitiv
ja ja genau warum schumacher weil bei
uns im globus gibt einen schuhmacher und
der tod immer die messe schreiben haben
wir nicht messer schleifgerät ja muss
man das kannst du doch nicht so viel
mein gott ich stadt oder wassermelone
so langsam kann man die form erkennen
[Musik]
jetzt muss ich hier oben nochmal ein
stück weg schneide weil da einfach ganz
viel schale noch dran hängt aber das
schmeißt jetzt bitte nicht weg sondern
könnt ihr das innere aufessen oder von
smallville nicht und mir kann ja auch
noch x-mal hier mit 3 du kannst es dann
weg nehme dann unten genauso mal
entweder müsste jetzt den durchmesser
kleiner machen oder hat die höhe und ich
mache lieber die höhe bis kleiner damit
die torte halt im durchmesser größer
bleibt wo ich ja auch noch ein stück zum
essen
die komplette schale muss halt jetzt
außen herum weg
[Musik]
das ist ein jahr wird es jetzt auch gern
essen ohne die bleiben die kleinen
malone sprechen besser
[Musik]
es ist hier einfach noch die reste weg
ob sie habe ich jetzt ein bisschen viel
weggesteckt
[Musik]
mit schneidet die wassermelone schön in
so eine zylinder form also so schön rund
einfach immer wieder am rand was weg was
man mit dem rechen jetzt auch machen
könnte das finde ich total lecker wenn
man die noch vermisst mit bislang zucker
kann man sie einfrieren und dann kann
man sich sowieso im vw machen
das ist auch leiter das kann man auch
mal machen müssen die mieter noch mit
rein
[Musik]
als nächstes nehme ich mir einfach eine
tortenplatte irgendeine und da setze ich
die melonen torte jetzt erst mal drauf
und muss einfach mal außen rum so ein
bisserl die feuchtigkeit wegnehmen damit
gleich die sahne daneben besser dran
haftet
und jetzt freu mich hier ganz schnell
aufholen meine sache aus dem kühlschrank
kann die steif schlagen und dann kann
ich endlich traute fries dekorieren also
eine richtig schnelle pitstop die
wassermelonen steht jetzt bereit und ich
hab jetzt hier 200 milliliter
schlagsahne und 250 gramm asab ohne man
könnte jetzt auch 400 gramm schlagsahne
nehmen oder ja was ihr halt wollt ihr
könnt auch quark benutzen was sie halt
gerade da habt die schlagsahne schlag
ist steif und gebt dann noch ein
bisschen salat mit rein einfach so zwei
teelöffel damit auch schon fest bleibt
[Musik]
und jetzt gerade noch ein bisserl die
mascarpone verrühren das mache ich jetzt
mal auf niedriger stufe ok auf hoher
stufe
das war cool ich war gekommen ist denn
die kann schon wehtun er hätte doch
größten stationen unterstütze da komm
ich führe das gleiche was capone rein er
in die saane rhein kann ich das zusammen
noch mal hören was kaputt ist immer
relativ fest und eigentlich hört man das
immer ganz gut durch beschlossen die
sahne geht aber sicher nicht schlimm was
zusammen gehört also das geht auch
[Musik]
so also sieht jetzt die creme aus ist es
schon eine relativ feste sahne creme und
jetzt seht ihr habt sie nicht gezögert
weil die melone ist ja schon süß genug
die früchte tier gleich drauf kommen
sind auch süß genug und deswegen
streiche ich jetzt einfach die torte
erstmal damit ein
also wieso eine normale torte
wenn man so eine palette mit dem messer
machen oder
ja das geht auch oder löffel es muss ja
auch perfekt drauf legen
und ich hab das jetzt heute zum ersten
mal mit mascarpone gemacht bisher habe
ich immer nur mit sahne gemacht damit
quark mit maria bonath mal den vorteilen
die chemisch wirklich relativ fest und
läuft halt er zu schnell runter also das
ist ein großer vorteil
ja ich denke mal wenn wir im sommer
gemacht und ist nach draußen so heißt
genau als es dann läuft halt viel
schneller runter muss man erst mal so
die erste schicht drauf kriegen und wenn
die drauf klebt dann geht auch recht gut
[Musik]
wenn ich sie dann ganz grob
eingestrichen haben können das so die
ränder einfach mit so einem kleinen
teich schauen wieder sauber machen dann
ist dort mit platten nämlich wieder
sauber ist nämlich die creme mit
verschwende und halt keinen silberpapier
dazu küchenpapier
[Musik]
da nehme ich mir hier so eine gezackte
teig karte mister nett aber ich finde es
ganz schön wenn man dann den rand damit
so ein bisschen verziert
[Musik]
ich habe ich die torte weitestgehend
eingedeckt und jetzt gebe ich die
restliche creme einfach machen sonst
trifft beutel mit nach stern thüle vorne
einfach darum jetzt wirklich wie eine
echte vorteile ausspielt wer jetzt
keinen spritzbeutel mit stern schüler
oder so hat der kann den schritt auch
einfach weglassen und die torte jetzt
nur noch mit den früchten verzieren
aber für mich gehört das einfach mit
dazu so und je nachdem wie groß sind
auch die wassermelone ist brauchte eben
auch mehr oder eben weniger creme also
bei mir war es eine relativ kleine
melone
ich bin jetzt ganz gut zurechtgekommen
mit der creme aber gerade so also
weniger dürfe doch nicht sein und kann
einfach sein dass sie einfach mittelmeer
cremt auch so
weil es spritze ich hier oben noch so
ein paar tupfer drauf
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich bereits mit der
dekoration beginnen
ich habe wie gesagt hier ein paar
früchte also hier habe ich beim team
bern und heidelberg und hier drüben noch
ein bisschen fußball ist entfernt und
eine stern frucht
[Musik]
seit nämlich mir zuerst an frucht und
die schneide es entscheiden
ich finde steinbruch ich hatte immer
schön aber ja besonders schmecken tut
sein gesundes voll genial wenn sie nur
nicht so teuer werden etwas stimmt und
ich habe auch jetzt mittlerweile gelernt
dass der streifen schwender außen hier
die ränder so bisserl braun sind wusste
ich nämlich auch nicht weil das macht
auch ein deutlicher unterschied
und jetzt halt wie ich sie mir aber noch
ich kann dann die hälften hier
reinstecken
[Musik]
und jetzt einfach mit einem rechtlichen
früchten so bisselik uhr ihren wie ihr
deshalb möchte
[Musik]
so murat ich habs jetzt fertiggemacht so
sieht sie jetzt bei mir aus ich hab da
und so kapital ist drum herum gelegt
weil sie sich eine obstsorte und ich
möchte auch dass man so viel mehr ob
stratmann kann sich das sind einfach mit
wegnehme wenn man möchte
und ja die johannesberger gibt noch
einmal johannisberg könnte man auch
gerade was stachelbeeren die
stachelbeere ich stelle jetzt erst mal
noch einen kühlschrank denn die torte
schmeckt besser wenn die wassermelonen
ihnen auch eben richtig kalt ist und
danach schneiden wir sie dann gleich an
also ich stellte jetzt erstmal so eine
stunde kühl
ihr könnt sie übrigens auch schon einen
tag vorher machen und am nächsten tag
erst essen das haben wir auch schon
ausgetestet also ein tag im kühlschrank
macht der torte gar nichts aber noch
länger würde ich so nicht stehen lassen
denn wir haben ja frische sahne dran und
die schmeckt dann irgendwann eben nicht
mehr so gut sagt murat wieso muss ich
jetzt noch gedulden und dann kam's
nerven perfekt jetzt ist die torte schön
kalt und kann angeschnitten werden
und ich überlege mir gerade eine gute
stelle wo ich das machen könnt am besten
einmal hier
ich hoffe dass die torte durch ist ich
habe die stäbchen pro bett gewacht
setzt sich der show auf der teller
morath krieg schon großes stück oder das
kann steht das cannstatter ein großes
stück zuerst man kann auch nicht man
kann sie auch leichten 23 stücke zu du
kannst darauf alleine essen beim letzten
mal habe ich eigentlich vorstandes habe
den technischen alleine gegessen
ich bin deine frau ich darf dresden die
startfreigabe benutzer ach glück dass
ich eine wassermelone nach gott
doch hier die deko mit dran so murat ich
glaub probieren wir's mal heut net oder
da doch ich probiere markus ist er gut
ist
mensch morath probiert so einfach weiter
völlig schiesst gleich noch mal fotos
der facebook unten instagram und habe
gut gemacht ja ja der schnitt so richtig
los
[Gelächter]
ich glaube ein rezept braucht man
eigentlich nicht aber ich schreibe euch
trotzdem die anleitung auf meinem blog
blog de und ja nach machen und sich vor
allem ich das finde ich ein cooler
gelten wenn man zum beispiel irgendwie
auf dem balkon eine party macht oder
grill bremgarten und man hat einfach
diese torte und im prinzip weiß er erst
mal keiner was drinsteckt und erst wenn
man sie an schneidet man eben das eine
wassermelone drin steckt also ich finde
es ziemlich lustig vor allem so eiskalt
schmeckte richtig gut
ja da wünsche ich ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder biss dann mit
transporter ich mein bild für instagram
für mein programm account gibt nicht an
gebt nicht an mit seiner follower
[Musik]
irgendwas irgendwas stehen drücken
ich hab zwar okay dass man
herausschneiden kurz mein auge
saubermachen